this morning north las vegas police are
investigating three separate murders
that happened just hours apart two
within a mile of each other near
cheyenne and civic center that's right
hector mejia joining us live outside
police headquarters in north las vegas
with the very latest on these
investigations hector good morning
hillary good morning police had a
violent labor day here investigating
three separate homicides and this
morning no word about arrests in any of
the three homicides the latest one
happened around nine last night on mary
d that's near cheyenne and civic center
officers say when they got to that
location they found a man suffering from
a gunshot wound he died there at the
scene we found detectives in the csi
unit trying to figure out who shot the
man the second homicide happened just a
few blocks away on civic center north of
cheyenne just an hour earlier around 8
p.m police say they found another man
who had been gunned down they rushed him
to the hospital where he died the first
homicide of the night occurred just
after 7 30 p.m when police say they were
sent to the area of las vegas boulevard
and bruce street in reference to a body
that was found there anyone with any
information is asked to give north las
vegas police a call their phone number
is
you know as soon as 702-633-9111 release
any new information on the three cases
reporting live in north las vegas hector
mejia 8 news now